get on the ground now don't move don't
move
all right man just pulling back here
it's my partner can give you a written
warning
is the car registered to you yeah okay
it's going back to the front of his car
let's step over here put your hands
behind your back do it now
together put it in
you just dropped the bag and it looks
like soap
[Music]
operas
yeah
all right
you're obviously not free to go
[Music]
I can tell you it came out of you it's
all on fucking camera
I mean whatever you might as well try to
lie you ain't got nothing to lose
everything else shoved up on you
we're gonna have to check that but
based on my training and experience if
we both I can already tell what it is
Walk This Way
all right
you didn't see anything uh
come out the car or nothing further down
yeah
just making sure
reason I stopped you when you pulled out
from the gas station
you had no lights on
and then you pulled out right in front
of another car
that's why I'm stopped that's the
biggest thing hey you know what you
forgot your I get it but
um hang tight back here with him for a
minute
just keep your hands out your pocket
swimming bus
you're good you can you can relax just
keep me in this pockets for me
foreign
[Music]
lay down on your face on your stomach
what's the matter with you man
13 Central
one secure in front of Oasis Apartments
you got any weapons during the monument
x-ray 13 Central
I'm good here you can clear the air I
ran with all this shit on after you so I
caught my breath you should be good
no they don't be in the jungle cardio
man
anybody around uh
Mason Washington first signal 12.
came out by Madison over in Daytona and
actually did a 180 and spun out the road
southbound Maplewood coming back out
towards Mason
Northbound quad just past Jimmy Ann
northbound
coming up with Bill France
on top of it
yeah 95 Northbound at LPGA
still westbound State Road 40 High rate
of speed just passed Timber Creek
Northbound State Road 11 rough 40.
okay they are parked at the 90 degree
turn
passengers out of the vehicle okay how
many occupants we got here one two three
three occupants bailed out of the
vehicle Clinton Cemetery Road at the
corner
yeah so far all three are together
they're just kind of huddled down in the
woods here
just south of the vehicle
chair sauce K-9 out yourself
Keep Your Hands Up
watch him buddy watch the Batman red
got you bread
you in the white shirt start crawling
white shirt start crawling
keep crawling
white shirt hands behind your back
don't move
yep coffee
good boy
get your hands up you're gonna get bit
all right hang on a second
there you go
you crawl out
that's good hands behind your back
don't move
he's inside okay
okay
there's somebody in there can we get
this thing flipped or not
you got someone submerged on the low
side
we need some help pushing
what
are you you're strong
[Music]
you got a cutter hey give me a knife
send her something
I got the board
two straps right over here
on that side too there's another top
girl victims executed
we'll be assessing in a moment peace out
there we go
foreign
awesome
all right
four seven Alpha foxtrot Echo Tango
hey Boris
foxtrot Echo Tango secure that in your
car
I'm out here at Stanford with Stanford
PD they are confirming that they have
armed targeting charges
[Applause]
he's moving he's running get on the
ground get on the ground the other one's
running grab them
foreign
right now
go to Walmart going to Walmart
standby canine's coming out with him and
in front of the Walmart by the liquor
store
what now
good we're good
we're good you're good I ain't doing
nothing man you didn't do nothing
yeah throw them in your car I'm gonna go
with canine
then on six
we got one question in front of Walmart
costumes
you want to go with them
[Applause]
stay at the 118. it's weaving in and out
of traffic there's nothing behind it
right now I missed the stick hit
[Applause]
[Applause]
here yet
here it comes coming to you it's coming
to you
got it got it got it
hey lock it down
[Applause]
okay not to your left to your left we
got people moving white shirt and a blue
shirt
hands are coming up hands are coming up
coming back out of the highway y'all yep
come back on the highway or uh
two subjects
that looks like both may have white
shirts on
walking back toward uh the guard rail
[Music]
s just one guy
Luke
foreign
[Applause]
we're actually looking for a lost child
he's been uh Missing for an hour now he
walked into the woods going westbound so
he's between your property and the next
street over
um if you see anything please give us a
call okay
uh three years
he was with the dog we found the dog so
we're still looking for him
where was it yeah
this is the property you were talking
about I appreciate it man thank you
what's up dude
the helicopter man
wow
what's up man got my hop off we've been
looking for you dude where have you been
where you been Buddy
what are you doing boy
big guy come here
what's up
call Tabby
tabby
and Luke Luke where were you buddy
dude we was looking for you
get out of where
oh
you want her to get out
yeah
he was asking about the dog
you want to go get her buddy
hey Clips what's his name clipso
over there is that clips though Eclipse
though
hold on buddy it's a barbar you can walk
up here come on
it's clip show
here Marty I'm gonna lift this Barbara
or Marty let's get this dog out uh oh
nobody don't no no no
no call clipso clipso
put that back down
okay he's exiting I-4 he's westbound uh
going to be westbound on I-4
yeah definitely at the older Honda Civic
green sticker in the back window
[Music]
would you guys hit him or not
found this
big hit under I-4 yeah he's continuing
westbound he's not taking the exit onto
Saxon
foreign
continuing West increasing speed
weaving in out of traffic now
spinning out guys looks like his tire
just went out he's just lost control
he's off to the median
[Music]
president
almost
all right he's off he's off again
spinning he's off he's in the he's in
the water in the water right hand side
even if you're covering each other Air
One car into the water
affirmative he's off to the right in the
water
he's in the ditch they have not exited
yet doors open but he has not exited
all right guys we're about to be able to
get hard covered
a one white male coming out the driver's
side he's not running there's also
another person inside the vehicle
[Applause]
step away from the car
here
[Music]
[Music]
yourself
hey one person calling
Stubbs bring her to me back back
stop get down on your knees
I forgot normal a little bit and then he
goes nuts again
off the right side of the road
I can't tell if he's taken 472 or not
yes he is he's gonna go eastbound
everyone's overhead we have them still
continuing four seven two toward I-4
motor 40 to air one do you see me up
here
he just crossed over he's in the
opposite lane right now I don't I have
my camera on him
[Applause]
he's in the opposite lane heading toward
I-4 he's in the shoulder on the grass
Now High rate of speed
okay he's coming up he's in the grass so
he's trying to cross around you
going up onto the sidewalk
[Music]
[Applause]
okay he's turning uh East by eastbound
Orange Camp back toward I-4
it's off the sidewalk he's back onto
Orange Camp okay he's going into Lake
Helen
he's driving around the house uh
just keep on coming all the way back if
anybody's following
I think he's coming back out standby
yeah he's coming out the way he came in
there he is right there
yeah through the fence out on I-4
eastbound now
okay he's slowing up he's in the grass
looks like he's exiting exiting on uh
LPGA
and he's going to be West uh standby now
he's uh eastbound on the westbound Lane
LPGA
he was crouched down now he's standing
up
by a tree looks like he's shirtless
and he's starting to move to the north a
little bit
so he's going moving a little to the
north
we are at the dog and the three guys are
going in now
let's do that in
he's hiding behind a tree peeking around
a tree looking for you guys
your dog's right bye
beside you can now right beside you K9
out your right side your right shoulder
five feet from you found a tree
get on the ground now don't move don't
move myself
[Music]
okay
negative hey now just stay back there
stop
please stop guys that's we're working on
it okay
stop moving your arms
but the kids ran out of the vehicle and
uh they're half naked which vehicle this
one right here
eyes rolling in the back of his head
yeah I'm in contact sir
I'm strong in his pocket as well
you guys don't need me anymore you guys
have a good day yeah okay yeah I got it
hey wake up wake up
wake up hey what are you doing all right
step out
step out step out
step out
step out
where are your kids at oh shit
you got some kids
no they're not his kids
step out
baby's children step over
who else you have in the car with you
who else was in the car with you
[Music]
listen to what I just asked you you know
who I am yeah you remember me yeah bye
who else is in the car with you
okay
and her kid right yeah okay where's the
girl at
I'm not in no trouble right
we're determining that we gotta find Mom
dudes in there
they have the kids yep little kids in
there no the kids are not in your car
they got out of your car
no they weren't with Mom they were with
you
okay
so I'm figuring it out
no they went with Walmart staff after
they ran in a parking lot and nothing
but a diaper foreign
at the steering wheel right
so for now put your hands worry about it
did somebody run your license yeah
can you hang out with the kids while I
talk to them come over here
we're gonna go over here
if you like watching high profile
criminal trials True Crime and unbiased
legal analysis make sure to subscribe to
our channel for daily videos I'm Dan
Abrams and you're watching the lawn
crime Network